[Musique]
voilà la chanson dussault qu'aucun ses
sonorités bears ce monde peuplé d'une
colonie d'oursons de l'aisne de tissus
et d'instruments de musique en bois un
univers destinés aux bébés dès l'âge de
six semaines
une expérience créée il y a neuf ans
inspirées par les voyages de soko en
asie ce qu'on y trouve beaucoup c'est
beaucoup de choses qui sont fabriqués et
confectionnés à la main avec avec des
beaucoup d'objets de récupération on
retrouve énormément de sonorité assez
vibratoire du cou qui sont là pour
vraiment stimulé les les premiers émois
des tout petits
le saut cocoon c'est aussi un langage
nouveau entre les parents et leurs
nourrissons une découverte sensorielle
du toucher et de l'ouïe
c'est le cas de matisse 13 mois avec son
papa patrice je pense qu'il a passé un
bon moment où il sait la déambulé il a
découvert pas mal de choses voilà je
pense que c'était un très bon moment en
famille ce spectacle vivant lance la
saison 2019-2020 du prisme à elancourt
une année culturelle placée sous le
signe de la pluridisciplinarité le
prisme c'est à la fois un lieu de
spectacle vivant évidemment c'est même
sa destination est essentielle à
l'origine mais nous accueillons aussi
maintenant au sein de l'équipe tout le
pôle enseignement artistique avec
l'école de musique de danse d'arts
plastiques
plusieurs activités organisées ce samedi
28 septembre dont un atelier d'arts
plastiques pour redécorer le bâtiment on
a décidé de mettre plein de couleurs sur
notre vitre avec du film adhésif
cette journée l'occasion aussi de
découvrir l'exposition cosmos 51 de
l'artiste thaddée le vernissage est
prévu le 11 octobre jour du concert de
guillaume perret au prisme